[Music]
have you ever wondered what it would be
like to live like a Sex in the City gal
I mean we all have right well here is
your chance because we're getting an
exclusive peek inside Kim Cottrell's
posh New York element just try not to be
jealous hi I'm Kim Cattrall and this is
my home in 90 seconds when I bought my
home there was no entranceway so we push
this wall way back so I have a place to
greet my guests thank luxury and glamour
in the 60 year olds Manhattan pad this
is my living room
also known as my tempo Aphrodite must be
kind of hard to keep all that white
furniture clean kim's home tour is for
Architectural Digest calm this is my
kitchen I'm more about entertaining but
I do love to cook
this is my office
also known as the monkey room Kim is
currently starring on the Netflix series
sensitive skin but we are all hoping for
a third sex in the city movie and her
iconic character of Samantha Jones and
the sooner the better
I can hear the decadence calling Kim and
her fellow castmates have hinted that a
movie comeback could be possible but in
the meantime how about just an invite to
hang out in that apartment this is my
fabulous bedroom we decided to go for
shades of pink it's kind of my sanctuary
with an added attraction
[Music]
you